good morning John it's Wednesday and
something about me has changed and it's
not my clothes right I'm wearing the
same gloves I was yesterday but
different hair and John this video is in
honor of you because you put this little
mean up on your website and I'm a big
fan of those old MySpace memes and I
kind of wish they wouldn't have gone
away I'm sad that they're gone and so
I'm bringing the meme into Brotherhood
2.0 a little bit here let's call this
meme for lack of a better name Google
verb it works like this you google your
name with a verb and then you find out
what you did here we go google verb
number one Hank needs Hank needs a hug
oh thanks everybody for that giant
YouTube hug Hank looks like Hank looks
like a pretty princess oddly enough that
one was actually about me it was the
title of the video and reference to my
world wide web girl video with the
pigtails yeah Hank says Hank says don't
rush to judgment which is good advice
Hank once Hank wants to play too but he
never gets - Hank does Hank does a dance
Hank hates Hank hates you all he doesn't
he doesn't he doesn't hate you Hank asks
thank asks what to do with the body and
mr. Bennet says for him to prepare it
for shipping scary
Hank likes Hank likes to watch men pee
on Flickr starting to get a little bit
upset about this Hank eats Hank eats a
glob of bacon grease and gets deathly
sick I'm not making these up I hope Hank
is not a person I hope think it's a dog
Hank where's Hank where's a golden
helmet while rafting the Zambezi River
pink sounds like he's having a very good
time Hank was arrested for Hank was
arrested for robbing the National Bank
of Greece but later found innocent
and finally Hank loves pink love Smosh
even though Smosh is spelled wrong
apparently I still love Smosh which is
true you guys you crack me up
anyway Hank's life sounds significantly
more interesting than mine what was the
rafting and watching people pee and so
on so all that's left now is for you to
play the Google verb meme - all you have
to do is do what I just did all the
questions are in the sidebar and believe
your video as a reply to this one I'm
going to go ahead and tag five people
because I want them to do this because I
think it would be funny I'm tagging
nerimon I think you all know why
dr. noise sister salad short sisters and
Pilates John I'll see you later